MODERATOR: Okay, and be mindful that there's gonna be a lot of luck, so please don't go that fast clicking on the dashboard because of the Internet is not that good.
P6: OK OK.
MODERATOR: So now i'm going to give you a remote control.
MODERATOR: So now, you should be able to move the mouse on the screen on the of the dashboard.
P6: So it's I can do it.
MODERATOR: Can you move the mouse, so we can see.
yeah.
MODERATOR: Is it moving on the screen or not.
MODERATOR: On the zoom screen.
MODERATOR: Yes, yeah Okay, and you can see, it is because there is a bit of lag.
MODERATOR: Between oh yeah no problem.
MODERATOR: So you want to start with the tasks and want to start the timer.
P6: Okay.
MODERATOR: And remember, to read out loud or and to speak everything that you're doing if you find it useful or not.
P6: Okay, so I read out smiled their task as well.
P6: As.
P6: What you see on your screen or two panels with labels left panel and main panel.
P6: With the Tesco we've been home tab and.
P6: In the main panel loud and explore a data source of your choosing by right clicking and opening in a new tab.
P6: Once you feel you understand where the data comes from please click the button open map to visualize the density of data.
P6: Points or even the location of Internet you will be done when you mentioned a few of their hello, I that have Dave point every level, you will be done when you mention a few of the.
P6: location of Internet that have data points available, so it starts by reading how.
P6: See the sc the dashboard.
P6: hides the come the complexities in linking clean calorie of disease data environment observations using knowledge graph.
P6: The desired outcome is to support has data researchers I then identify appropriate environmental variables, to enable their hypothesis exploration in researching rare disease, how to use the dashboard select and submit the querying boots on the left.
P6: explore the resulting the link environmental data that appear after cleaning submit.
P6: explored or insulting.
P6: and export the data for your needs a text file named user query story is of my ethical is saved in the APP local folder with the story of your query put selections you will be able to use this fight to get the data directly through an API in the future, or API.
P6: And another big okay data means environmental observation have been gathered from the following source their their pollution and.
P6: aerosol they saw okay data points density click the button and.
P6: or.
P6: Over to me just to get the number of data option.
P6: oops.
P6: Read the test the text.
P6: So I have to choose open map no.
P6: input.
P6: With the test within home tab in the main panel or loud and explore data.
P6: By right clicking and opening it in.
P6: This is.
P6: It no OPS.
P6: So open map have to open these I can't understand.
P6: Once you feel you understand where the data comes from.
P6: Even tough interest, oh no here.
P6: So oh it's just show me about map for.
P6: Okay input.
MODERATOR: Please could you finish school.
P6: Finish task one.
P6: Okay.
P6: event of interest.
P6: So can I have more time.
P6: This is.
MODERATOR: you're going to read you're going to have as much time as you want, if you want to read again does one, so you make sure you understand.
Okay.
P6: I have to I I write the test and i'm sure I, I understand that part okay so once you feel you understand where the data comes from I understand them okay open map to visualize density of data and you will be done okay so it's done and I have to go to task to.
MODERATOR: You will be done when you mentioned a few Lol is that you have that the bones of a local.
P6: location of.
P6: I have to choose the location here you mean.
P6: i'm not sure about us to.
Mention.
MODERATOR: You have to mention a few that have data points available.
P6: Okay.
P6: Which part show me data is available currently in.
P6: Motion turning seven, there are three and data point density tree, what is the meaning of data point and said okay.
P6: So I can understand, then data is available and Dublin in Dublin yeah.
P6: So I got to test to.
P6: submit a query using the input option available in the query tab on the Left button okay.
P6: honey.
P6: oops.
P6: While you are selecting the query options, please explain allow the specific choices that you make, as you make choices new ones will become available for you to select.
P6: As you reach the end, please click the submit button once which will only be available if valued valid inputs have been selected, you will be done when a new tab named q1 is displayed in the main panel of the dashboard please only submit one query.
P6: Just one query.
P6: oops.
P6: He or a data, what is the or a data environmental updates.
P6: way I can change this part oops I was that.
P6: Okay location of interest.
P6: Okay.
P6: date range was date range.
P6: There isn't any date range they're just.
P6: For example.
P6: Our guest to.
P6: oops.
P6: well.
P6: I want weather and pollution.
MODERATOR: you please tell me why you selected Ireland.
P6: Because.
P6: I don't know honestly I just see I I selected the location of data dog, so I guess maybe it's to explain I Dublin in Ireland, you know, maybe I thought, maybe it's.
P6: Dublin is in Ireland, and I wanted to clarify that my meaning about Dublin in Ireland, not in any place with the same name.
MODERATOR: And when I go REG you here we go.
P6: Another point is.
MODERATOR: Sorry, I want to correct you just Ireland means all the counties in Ireland so for the whole the country.
MODERATOR: Oh only dabbling but everything.
P6: So I have to remove these yeah.
P6: yeah okay.
P6: and hopes.
P6: temporality your needs.
P6: Early daily monthly yearly.
P6: well.
P6: This is tempera why.
P6: i'm sorry.
P6: Daily monthly or yearly well.
P6: Maybe daily.
P6: As it's Okay, I can use its meaning if I want.
P6: pay.
P6: Especially should.
P6: shoot him.
P6: Could you could you.
P6: expound the first word aggregation before aggregation it's means oh Okay, I understand I mean.
P6: minimum maximum.
P6: hopes.
P6: I just use one of them, I would like to choose, for example, more than one option in every parts.
P6: I choose mean but, for example, I can have.
P6: Harley monthly daily early you know it's, and I mean mike's meaning.
P6: it's good be if it's could be good if I can use this.
P6: And I can't understand about this part.
P6: My mouse, let me he oh I dates, what is your dates.
P6: What is that I can't find it in the.
P6: date.
P6: ups.
P6: Come on.
P6: I don't know.
MODERATOR: If you want to move forward.
P6: yeah so I have to stop me.
P6: My query.
P6: is submitting yeah I guess.
P6: Okay.
You can.
P6: test three.
P6: Okay explore explore the question one tap in in order to understand table.
P6: underneath there are two buttons that help.
P6: Two buttons that will.
P6: help you interpret the data table that you see click those buttons on top open querying put summary and open color table the script Chan okay and commenting.
P6: On their usefulness and clarify as explanations then or read the text in the data.
P6: Data sub tab and talk through the entire presentation of the variables and so background colors red and blue of the data table, you can select the columns that you want to display with their target accounts bottom now that you can scroll vertically and.
P6: curly and use the page.
P6: And the right bottom corner to check the amount of data that you query by a scrolling.
P6: You will be done when you feel you have sufficiently explore these tables okay.
P6: So i'm here, this is my prairie and.
P6: The variables, which, let me open query input summary.
P6: Right it's.
P6: disease and vasculitis island.
P6: Definition high probability possible know doubling.
P6: weather pollution.
P6: there's page okay period and good time frequently and aggregation effort okay fine.
P6: it's that's good, I think there isn't it's a summary of my book, yes, so I can check it.
P6: In short time and often color table description rare disease.
P6: He will I.
P6: OK OK table color.
P6: If POPs.
P6: database background if data is normally distributed 95% should be between okay.
P6: values.
P6: are high and.
P6: Hopes great so you.
P6: know.
P6: So you added this information today great great great like this point.
P6: oops oops I want to check.
P6: This part I can Okay, so I check these two parts and go to commenting I committed then write the text in the data.
P6: and talk through the.
P6: Okay i'm trying to read the test.
P6: But oops.
P6: Sorry.
P6: it's not working, OK.
P6: OK, the flu name of the variables, will the uni.
P6: appear when.
P6: Over the data table for further information, please refer to the data sources links in the.
P6: tap the attack of columns button allows to select select the columns of interest.
P6: For example, year columns of interest and explore by them to download the data as a csv file to your computer Ali the visible columns will be downloaded.
P6: Year months, so you put here a list of variables.
P6: and
P6: Okay.
MODERATOR: Let me close it because you are downloading into my computer one second.
P6: Okay, oh.
P6: So.
P6: That this is great, but also have this option are great you know see us is really useful and explain about every column will air air temperature and it's.
P6: it's great great great yeah it's lovely.
P6: Yes, good.
P6: And paige.
P6: Just we can show.
P6: The number of.
P6: Okay.
P6: Yes, oops.
P6: So.
P6: You can select the columns that you want to display with the tag it was great now that you can scroll virtually and.
P6: What that means a scroll virtually and oops oops.
MODERATOR: This.
P6: Okay.
P6: and use the page arouse.
P6: Great.
P6: You will be done when you feel you have sufficient they explore this data yeah it's good.
Okay.
P6: split disperse go to task for explore the other tab beside the data table.
P6: Three plots time series box plot and.
P6: blood.
P6: interactive with features for this for different purpose, please use these features okay.
P6: Time series.
P6: Will plot.
P6: legend do you explain about plot.
Where.
P6: Do I want what I think I have a mistake.
P6: Okay, I wanted to zoom it more.
P6: template.
P6: variables so click and drag to select the period of interest on the button plot.
P6: What that means, like it's not clear for me disruptions.
P6: chair zone.
P6: yeah and pen zooming.
P6: zoom out.
P6: This part time series.
P6: Definitely, people who are professional use this part but for others it's maybe need to.
P6: add some information about you know it's some missy.
P6: Maybe the first view will be better.
MODERATOR: The owner rate again once in the legend their.
P6: Land legend.
P6: And the text.
MODERATOR: The text on the top.
MODERATOR: This.
This.
P6: oops yeah.
MODERATOR: So these again.
P6: yeah it makes it makes it easier definitely click the variable to oh.
P6: So what happened, I click on rain.
P6: Oh uh how disappear.
P6: It disappears, it will.
P6: disappear by clicking on them okay.
P6: You can put just so I have to click on I left him to disappear them.
P6: And just put oh great great yeah.
P6: snow it's good.
P6: Well, it would be better at the first will be this type and just click one of them, and to.
P6: show this show this and show this, for example.
P6: Okay box plots well, but what is good for a complete view, so the box bounds their IQ are waiting by the.
P6: turkeys.
P6: standard to a maximum of.
P6: soapbox point is good.
P6: Okay, so it's like others it's you can choose owner it's it's at the end of that yeah it's good good good and.
P6: plot plot.
P6: scatter four plots complex variables wind.
P6: Try this legend to give us the Queen to speed and.
P6: Clark lot I don't I can't understand what the meanings of polar but the beam direction.
P6: visualize is interactive twilight zone.
P6: Option Oh, for every.
P6: OK.
P6: OK kiki.
P6: Oh that's fine.
P6: was thinking to put, how do you want to show polar flat Okay, so there is no guys, you can see.
P6: frequency of preeclampsia.
P6: Every.
P6: yeah it's great.
P6: it's great.
P6: Fine, fine.
P6: Okay, so.
P6: You will be done when you have explore to the interactive.
P6: features for each of okay so go to the create two new queries after you have submitted them following the same instruction in the step two, you will see a question to question three as new tabs on the main panel know you can compare them in the comparative.
P6: tab read the text in this tab, and so let me just well I submitted one query I am hi I have to go to the second query.
P6: So for a second query I just have to let me.
P6: after you have submitted.
P6: To nuclear queries.
P6: Well, can I select two new queries.
P6: This is one query.
P6: Okay.
P6: True.
P6: Okay, you can tantra is i'm ready to.
MODERATOR: Make sure you click on the date range behind because you haven't selected anything.
P6: yeah i'm click here so.
P6: one hour OK.
P6: And click here for me okay.
MODERATOR: that's what exactly what you did before.
P6: yeah I want to change this cart.
MODERATOR: Perfect perfect.
Okay.
P6: Okay, so stuff means.
P6: What happened.
P6: And no, I have a query.
P6: to another query.
P6: Maximum.
P6: wine.
P6: So it's a good point to save all of my queries and i'm just wondering if I can, for example.
P6: Have a query for a lying you know for for a huge data.
P6: Okay, so.
P6: There is other the same auction for all of these.
MODERATOR: If you.
MODERATOR: Ask again.
P6: yeah okay.
P6: OK step two, you will see q2 q3 as a new tabs on the mail and know you can compare them in the comparative tab of yes explain comparative tab.
P6: So oops oops oh.
P6: Credit data previously submitted in this section can be come paired by specific a specific variables, you can combine these queries into group.
P6: With multiple selection inputs to potentially increase the signal to noise.
P6: ratio you decide the number of groups.
P6: That you wish to compare select which queries you want to group.
P6: and explore hmm and survivors with different words queries are computing the may appear unit of time in The Times there's blood and by can.
P6: values in the okay therefore time series plot as a limitation when comparing queries with different okay so click to generate groups.
P6: number of groups oh one.
P6: group one.
P6: it's true, let me check it and new inputs paragraph will appear under arrange your queries in the groups and click on click to plot groups.
P6: Okay, no new sub tabs will have appeared with Treaty friend visualization.
P6: clicked part.
P6: Two please mention.
P6: hello to use his fullness of H1 in a similar manner to step three okay.
P6: Well time series box and.
P6: yeah, for example, for rain.
P6: Okay.
P6: i'm Okay, the key key, so this is is.
P6: This is for select first compare groups.
P6: I can't understand clearly.
P6: I.
P6: I can't Andre spent this parts, maybe I have.
P6: You know date time.
P6: Yes, I can choose more than one.
P6: No just one by one okay.
P6: The same time okay oh good group one.
P6: Data value.
P6: group one.
P6: I put both of them in a group and.
P6: I can't understand how they compare it yeah.
P6: Very punctual plan.
P6: eight.
P6: Values what.
MODERATOR: This man, maybe try to groups.
MODERATOR: behind it, because you are comparing groups not Gladys.
Oh.
P6: Yes, me.
MODERATOR: You need to generate you need to again.
P6: Okay, so here, I put two groups click on generate.
P6: Oh.
P6: So.
P6: click to.
P6: Oh OK so.
P6: For one.
P6: Now okay.
P6: Here is group one rain group to rain or.
P6: Close to all of this is the remaining I guess and group stream axiom.
P6: yeah great.
P6: But it's an Andre standing Sunday sport, I think, neither workshop.
P6: or.
P6: box plot and.
P6: Others.
P6: We can oh yeah we can export them so okay.
P6: What is this error.
MODERATOR: that's that's for me, let me.
P6: One second okay yeah.
MODERATOR: that's what I mean you can continue like no.
Okay.
P6: Okay.
MODERATOR: You can continue.
MODERATOR: to select one.
P6: Okay, fine.
P6: Fine, this is fine, can I have more than, for example, born valuable in the same time.
P6: However, we can no, no, you can.
P6: The same time export yes download the and yeah there is option for them, thank you say.
P6: down those slots so and then click on.
P6: The input prayer groups will know will appear on their peer groups arrange your queries in the group and click on clean to plan, no new.
P6: Well, please mentioned allowed to see useful, it was a good in this part is more useful, yes, no I like to compare something with each other to one of the queries to export and go that.
P6: tues, for example.
P6: query one.
P6: I think.
P6: and go that tab click the export button from the data table to download the data as a csv file finally open the seat download tab on the.
P6: left side panel and click on download sleep with all data data basis to download all data or all the queries submitted during the session as a zip file, you will be done when understanding, where the data is stored okay so.
P6: I selected these go to bottom.
P6: bottom.
P6: I can't find.
MODERATOR: Do you want to keep again okay.
Okay.
MODERATOR: Just just that's fine.
P6: I don't need to do to choose to export the data.
MODERATOR: No it's fine like if you know what it is it's fine.
P6: Oh yeah I know.
P6: They.
MODERATOR: don't do the task.
P6: Finally, could you summarize.
MODERATOR: Before that there's another step that you missing task.
six.
P6: Which part.
P6: task 666.
P6: yeah I have to export.
MODERATOR: Know six if you can finish the butter, please.
Okay.
P6: choose one of the.
P6: queries to export and go that tab click the export button from data table to download data so i'm interested in this.
P6: But keep going.
P6: keep going no.
P6: chance show anything.
MODERATOR: Well, it happened.
MODERATOR: To my computer but.
MODERATOR: If you can keep reading, please.
P6: Oh okay.
P6: Open this oh yes.
P6: You explain on the part.
P6: download sleep with on data say zip file downloaded is located, for their names APP files.
P6: Okay.
perfect.
P6: to download on data for all the queries submitted during the session as a zip file, you will be done.
P6: So where is.
P6: Where is despite.
MODERATOR: Despite my computer.
P6: Oh, in your computer.
P6: Okay, fine.
P6: So.
MODERATOR: If you want to move to the next task.
yeah.
P6: Finally, could you summarize verbally your all your experience in completing his task facing dash Burke, then please prices.
P6: Complete.
P6: So generally it's a good and well done honestly I liked most part of these just about you know, having more option in the same time, for example, for temporal units or others or maybe.
P6: i'm not sure, but.
P6: I think users to use this.
P6: This ashford are different have different disciplines so be sure that all of.
P6: All of users can use it easily and also, I think it's it's easy and honestly I enjoyed working with them it's more easier than other.
P6: Other data sets or dashboards like this word before.
P6: Justice so excellent well done.
MODERATOR: Okay, thank you very much for having.
No, no.
MODERATOR: i'm going to stop there, and.
MODERATOR: Stop the remote control stop the sharing and.
MODERATOR: Stop the recording.